[Musique]
les espagnols sont très fiers de leur
jambon séché il y a le serrano qui est
l'origine provenaient des montagnes
attendu serrano pas ça c'est le plus
populaire et le plus vendu par tous ces
sacs un produit plus vite sa queue on
peut faire une grosse quantité qu'ils
soient de fabrication artisanale ou fait
à grande échelle la base est là mais
c'est du port que l'on salle et que l'on
fait sécher le serrano si la charcuterie
de tous les jours avec laquelle on fait
des sandwichs et qu'on cuisine comme
nous le démontre le chef du restaurant
ibérique hausse à montréal ici avec des
choux de bruxelles des artichauts ou
encore des moules
mais en dégustation c'est plutôt le
jambon ibérique qu on vous servira quand
tu utilises un même technique sur la
race de porc ibérique
ce hacker tu peux avoir une meilleure
qualité
le jambon ibérique provient des ports de
race pata negra à pattes noires il est
élevé en pâturage lors de l'élaboration
du jambon ibérique
il y à la période où la pièce de viande
est recouverte de sel pendant au moins
une semaine
puis le séchage qui peut atteindre
jusqu'à 4 ce qui détermine sa qualité et
sa saveur
mais pour les espagnols le nec plus
ultra c'est le jambon ibérique de
bellota le port pata negra et non
seulement en liberté et se nourrit de
pâturages naturels mais à la fin de sa
vie il mange de six à sept kilos de
glands par jour qu'on appelle en
espagnol les b you tu as ça tu manges
tout seul température ambiance un gars
qui est beaucoup plus fonda équivalait
se promener entre et risque donc
les résultats exceptionnels sur ma
chique à oz et l'associé de est sam au
restaurant ibérique hausse il est un des
rares à pratiquer le métier de maître
cooper à montréal mais le m cooper peut
préparer une assiette en deux ou trois
minutes tandis que novice pendant 15 à
20 minutes pour y arriver les prix
procès jambon espagnol varie
considérablement
pour se procurer du serrano vous devrez
débourser environ 7 dollars les sangles
il vous en coûtera trois fois plus pour
le jambon ibérique est cinq fois plus si
vous optez pour le jambon ibérique de
bellota donc on a serrano les ibériques
aux ibériques ob liotta ok qu'est ce que
je devrais goûter comme différence entre
ces 2 par exemple
ben a vraiment la cérémonie devrait être
plus ferme de faire un petit peu plus à
l'est je veux y aller avec les doigts
c'est la meilleure façon c'est là
qu'habite finale ça l'est ouais alors
qu'ici on voit quand même ça c'est déjà
un petit peu plus - le moins sec autre
chose et là ça s'est fait avoir
alors la finale c'est un peu noisette
c'est plus complètement chose direction
centre ville de montréal
au restaurant iberica où l'on sert un
des jambons ibériques de bellota les
plus rares le josélito c'est ferran
adria du célèbre el bulli en espagne qui
l'a fait découvrir aux gastronomes du
monde entier aux ibériques a pour des
raisons d'efficacité on t'a et celui ci
en utilisant une trancheuse manuel haut
de gamme des jeux sont possiblement le
2,3 à attendre de son élan s'oppose
cependant comme en espagne au portugal
on a une âme manger dans sa loge pour la
trancheuse qui beaucoup plus rapide on
l'a commencé à acheter des os et du
racket des poumons
si vous permettez j'entends un petit
morceau du monde cruel
le goûter les outre les différences non
non à ok c'est ça donc on voit ni
l'audace et la couleur est différent le
grand terrain quand les gens voient
celui-là il dit bob graham et je dois
les hôtes ont envie ce gr parce qu'enfin
quand il ya 40 à 50% selon qui tout à
fait douce et cette marge s'était léger
aussi c'est pas salé des gens pensent
que ça l'est oui c'est salé sucré
seydoux plusieurs se targue de fabriquer
le meilleur jambon du monde mais une
chose est certaine le goût et la texture
du jambon ibérique en font un produit
unique